You Suck rhymes like mine can't be
beat. That hurts my feelings. Oh, sorry.
Do you want to play Pokemon
go instead? Sure. Yes.
Hello world. It's Saroj and
I am a big fan of rap music.
There's plenty of rap that degrades women,
promotes violence,
and glorifies the gangster lifestyle.
But for all of its negatives,
wrap is also a medium for
some incredible storytelling.
It's a glimpse into real human suffering
in a hopeless place, a cry for justice,
a distillation of the
human spirit of rebellion,
and it's not just the content of rap
that's compelling, it's the style.
Let's not even think about the subject
matter for a second rack gives you a
certain lyrical freedom that
newly no other musical genre can.
It's all about the rhymes.
There's the perfect rhyme words
that end with the same sound.
There's also the assonance rhyme where
only vowel sounds are shared like,
and so because there's so much
creative potential in the rap game,
we might need to introduce a
digital mc to the scene. Am I right?
What if we could get a machine to
understand rack lyrics or even write them?
It's not like this stuff
hasn't been tried before.
It has several attempts have been made
to try and understand lyrics using
machine learning. But one attempted
particular got some really great results.
A pair of researchers
at Hong Kong University,
so I had to download the
lyrics to 52,000 rap songs.
Then train a model so that given a
novel song and model could identify it's
rhyme scheme. So you ate a big Mac, your
breadth is whack, you need a tic tac.
Take the whole pack is an example of the
AIA rhyme scheme since all the ending
words Ryan, whereas life is a dream
future is now I eat ice cream.
They're not saved. Gabel is an example of
a, B, a, B. Since every other line writes,
the model they use to train on the
lyrics was called a hidden Markov model.
Let's remove the word hidden for a second
and talk about how a plain old Markov
model works.
Let's say we want to predict the weather
and let's also say that the weather can
only be one of three states, either sunny,
cloudy, or rainy for a hundred days.
We record the weather and record
the transition between each day.
Whenever we want to find the probability
of the weather being a certain state
after a given day,
we can just tally the number
of transitions of that
type and divide the number
of days by 100 that's
how Markov models work.
They help us predict the likelihood of
a future state. Pretty useful. Right.
But what about a hidden Markov model?
Well,
suppose we can't directly
observe the weather,
so we can't really calculate
the transition probability.
So the model is hidden from us,
but we can observe related phenomenon
like the number of people with umbrellas
on a given day because Rihanna said so.
So using one of many techniques,
we can still find ways to calculate the
transition probabilities using these
related variables.
So Hidden Markov models are pretty cool
and their entire textbooks devoted to
how they work.
In fact,
it can be used not just to classify
lyrics but generate them as well.
That same pair of researchers
published a later paper,
but you know how during a Cypher one
MC challenges another with a verse.
Then the opponent is supposed
to spit back some sick rhymes.
They trained hmm to do this.
The results were interesting,
but let's just say they're digital. Mc
wasn't exactly the second coming of Tupac.
Let's take a look at a fresh approach.
A group of researchers published a paper
just last month called dope learning,
a computational approach to rap lyrics,
generation legendary.
They use an algorithm called rank Svm,
which was partially powered by a deep
neural network and they fed it a data set
of all the songs from the top
100 English speaking rap artists.
No idea how Lil Wayne got on that list.
So how does this algorithm work? Well,
first they needed to extract features
from their rap corpus to feed to their
model and they wanted features that
represented three metrics, rhyming,
structural similarity and semantic
similarity. I'll those three metrics.
The semantic similarity was the one that
required the use of a deep recurrent
neural network and neural
net did what it does best.
It found vector representations of words,
lines and groups of lines.
Once the features were calculated,
they were input into the rink.
Svm model rake SBM is a support
deck machine by the way,
which is just a type of linear classifier
and the SPM eventually learn to
predict the next line once who
was trained on the input features.
They also want it to find a way to
quantify how good their algorithm was
compared to human MCS and so they
calculated something called rhyme density,
which is the average length of the longest
Ryan per word using rhymed density as
a metric.
They found that the algorithms generated
lyrics had a 21% higher density and the
most rhyme dense human artists on their
list and inspect a deck play who let's
write our own Rappler, his generator
using a hidden Markov model in Python.
We only need two dependencies here,
random,
which helps generate random numbers and
re which helps deal with text formatting.
Our highest level of method
is called test Markoff in.
It will initialize an
empty array called rap,
lied and add all of our lyrics to
the rap library and returned the wrap
generated from the rap library using the
stop word that was input by the user.
The generated wrap.
We'll always start with the stop word.
Let's take a look at
the ad to live function.
It opens the lyrics file and construction.
Hmm.
It iterates through every word and checks
this record to see if it's a new word
or sequence. If a word or a sequence has
appeared before, he won't rerecord it,
then it changes each count to a percentage
value or a transition probability.
So once we constructed our model,
we can run the make rocks function.
It'll take both the set of lyrics
and the start word as the parameters.
It will continuously generate words.
You have the markup next function
for up to 50 words. The markup.
Next function either
returns a random word,
it's the word it's novel or find a
word from the model. Probabilistically,
let's test this out and
see what it generates.
I'll start off my wrapper with homie.
Homie grows Bunani likely
on Toten inspired enough,
basically, boy coming periods.
Damn.
So dope.
Check out the links down below for more
info and please subscribe for more ml
videos. For now. I've got to
go fix a malformed requests,
so thanks for watching.